I don't care about tragedies all over the world because I can't,
some people claim to care about all injustices,
but what does that even mean to care means to give serious attention or
consideration,
apply to doing something correctly or to avoid damage or risk two set thing.
If you acknowledge that's the serious problems in this world require labor
intensive solutions. How can you care about everything and a world?
Will we acknowledging importance of commitment and discipline?
We also apparently have people who believe they can be committed to everything,
make it make sense, sway. Well, this is the type of thing a boy would say.
When trying to convince a Mangus woman to accept a polyamorous relationship,
baby, I could love you all equally. You can't,
you might acknowledge that it's sad. You may feel that it's wrong,
but to implies that you are willing to do the work.
When is the last time you told your friends you were going to work and came back
10 seconds later, after posting on Twitter, I'm done with my shift,
hashtag civil rights movement, hashtag and slavery, Martin Luther king,
somewhere rolling in his grave saying, oh,
I had a dream and you lazy Negros had a tweet. You may say you care,
but what choices are you actively making to state in informed?
Are you donating your money? Are you giving your time to all these causes?
Are you putting in any work for the vast majority of worldwide issues?
Of course not because you can't,
you don't win a war by fighting on every frontier.
You do it by picking your fights, your battles,
and trusting others to handle the respective issues. Another thing is that we,
as a society have to accept that while the internet is a wonderful tool.
It's also brought us an information overlord that has jarred our minds.
The paradox of choice is an observation that many options to choose from can be
an issue rather than making people happy, ensuring that they get what they want.
It can cause them to stress. As a consequence,
decision making processes can become stalled. Well, the paradox of endless em,
empathy of phenomenon, I came on,
I came up with observation that in trying to empathize with everything often,
it turns us apathetic to the world, the sort of numbing effect, if you will.
I got that way very fast with a lot of issues, whether it be police shootings,
whether it be mass shootings, whether it be, um,
to just stories on the news in general,
I just became numb after some time because you just see it always.
And so I often, and while this might seem terrible,
it's also like a very like natural survival instinct. You know, it's like, um,
I used to have this guard when I lived in Ethiopia,
he used to walk around everywhere, barefoot. And I'm like,
it's not like these are paved roads. You know, these are Rocky spots. And
he, he had the biggest feet I'd ever seen in my life.
Like its like the Amer opposite of like an American body builder.
You know, like they're all like upper body and, and no legs.
He was all feet and no body. You know, he was super Ethiopian in a way,
but he had like these thick Cowes on the bottom of his feet.
And the reason being is that he walked on rocks for so long.
His body naturally adapted. He could didn't feel his feet anymore.
Like you could put a needle inside. He wouldn't feel it.
I feel like our relationship with a lot of world issues is very similar
assimilating.
All this suffering has made us cynical.
It's convinced us that the world is gonna end.
Despite the fact that we're in a better place today than we were 15,
80 years ago,
you know where our grandparents opened up the local newspaper and heard about
issues within their country.
We now open our phones at every day and hear about
suffering on a global scale.
It's too much and we're not coping well rather than accept this.
We project our inability to cope onto others.
Sham them for not showing the dedication to causes.
We often can't do much for ourselves or worse.
We expect them to dedicate themselves to causes we hold dear. And if they don't,
we pass judgment whilst not acknowledging that we ourselves have ignored causes
important to other people. Yes,
but Palestine is a genocide and Yemen 130,000 people have died in the last year
or so in Ethiopian. Ethnic cleansing is underway. As we speak in China,
Yers are being erased off the face of the earth.
And in case you forgot we're in the middle of a pandemic,
which has not only shifted our lives completely,
but also claimed millions of people's lives, tragedies all around us.
And I'm not talking about TikTok videos or my hairline or anything like that.
It is a constant everywhere. We look every day,
people are dying and we're all affected to different degrees depending on our
proximity to the issue.
But to sit there and say, mine is more important.
So you should care is incredibly arrogant to claim your tragedy should take
precedent on whose authority who said you hold a high ground on virtue O B
one y'all are tiring. And your virtue signaling is so toxic.
You can compete with Cher, noble, honestly,
even writing this piece has been exhausted.
Maybe it's because I'm out of to give. Maybe I'm the problem.
Everyone else is more virtuous than I. And if so, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that I don't give a about the tragedy that you're going through.
That hurts. That's probably insensitive,
but since so many of you don't want to,
since so many of you want to hear my thoughts on things that I never cared about
here it is. I don't give a.
And this doesn't mean I want you to fail.
This doesn't mean I want people to be hurt.
This doesn't mean that I want things to go terribly for folks.
It just mean is that whether things go well or not,
I'll probably feel indifferent and I refuse to pretend otherwise. So yeah,
I guess I don't, I'm too busy, um,
cleaning my room <laugh> so, you know, if you wanna stick around, you know,
or if you don't wanna stick around and up subscribe, I understand that's fine.
It's cool. You're right. Uh, but if you do then, you know,
we'll keep talking about meat and sips and whatever,
and that's it. Other than that, I guess, uh, you know, hashtag free Palestine,
what are your thoughts?
Essentially? This channel is really just things that we want to talk about.
It's what it is at the bottom of it.
It's things that we, the two names on this channel,
Abba and preach want to talk about.
We don't have to,
we don't have to have to talk about anything.
We don't have to. It's not a, a, we don't have a job. We don't have an employer.
We don't have to. It's not something. When you send us a topic,
know that it's a suggestion. We don't have to talk about it.
If you wanna talk about it, we will. That's all that.
That is thing that we want to talk about.
We've turned down numerous TV opportunities
and collabed with other shows,
just for the freedom of wanting to talk about what we want to talk about when we
want to talk about it. <affirmative> what we want to do is dope.
and things that we want to do. That's it, that's what this channel is.
It's not the news network.
It's not your local news network that is linked to the government.
It's none of that. They,
they have a job to do as a journalist.
They have something to do to inform, to find the truth.
That's what they do. News outlet. I mean,
that's what they're supposed to do.
We're entertainers
Before anything. And if it happens to be serious, the,
and it's gonna be serious.
And if it happens to be funny, well, that's what we do. We entertain.
But we are under no obligation to do anything and to talk about anything.
Even if they're close to us, we've said that before, we'll repeat it right now.
There's some things going on in the Haiti. There's some things on in Ethiopia,
we didn't talk about it.
We don't have to talk about all these subjects.
Someone not talking about something, someone not posting a square,
a black square, a blue square, a red square. Uh, I justly just,
just like, it just doesn't change anything.
It makes you feel better.
Doesn't mean that they care. That's what I gotta say. Mm.
You know,
for those of you at home who are feeling a tremendous amount of anxiety because
of the fact that there's so much going on everywhere, you know,
understand it's not your responsibility to take everything on.
It's not, and you can't,
and you're not doing a good job by trying to all you do is you spread yourself
thin you spread yourself thin,
and then you end up not contributing at all in any kind of meaningful way.
I thought about it for a long time.
I thought about my indifference to certain things.
And I realized it's just basically a simple survival mechanism.
I just there's too much input. And so you have, you, you,
you end up becoming numb to certain things. I'm not saying it's a good thing.
I'm not saying it's bad. I don't know. It's just something that I really live.
And you know, maybe none of y'all are numb.
Maybe you guys feel everything all the time. I'm not that way, essentially.
I just don't want you guys thinking that you have to do all of this. Um,
I don't think it's healthy nor do I think it's manageable. And, um,
there's a real, you know, phenomena, the idea that people consume too much news.
So they start to feel like real anxiety and depression. That's real,
that's real. And so, you know, especially as, as creators,
we get sent every tragedy in the world all day long, the worst things,
the worst people you get sent to us every single day.
Cause I think everybody wants us to echo whatever it is that they're feeling.
And you know,
the only way for me to manage my mental health as well is to say no to certain
things. Um, and so, you know, if you're, if you're one of those people,
who's like, yeah, people, I feel like you're ignoring, Hey, listen,
I don't wish that on anybody. Um,
but there are certain things I have to protect. And, uh, I,
I wanted to write this because
People were trying to make me feel bad about telling the truth.
You know, what I'm saying is just a very real reflection of,
of the reality of our, of our planet, of the people that live on it.
If everyone cared about everything, everything would get solve.
People don't care. Not because they're unaware.
A lot of the times they just don't want to be informed.
They don't want to look into it.
You actively trying to not learn about something is also a choice.
So understand whether you get mad at me or not. That's the truth of our world.
And if you wanna get mad at the world, get mad, but that truth is, you know,
but if you just mad at me, cuz I'm the messenger for that, then whatever it is,
what it is.
Well, it's hard, it's hard to, to, to get mad at the world, right? Yeah.
You know, because you sent that. Yeah. You're the face of that. Exactly.
So it's easier to get mad at you yeah.
Than to get mad at society and every single people in the society.
Now the thing is that happened with that truth is that it's ugly. It's ugly,
you know, and some people, they really,
they rather have a beautiful light and the ugly truth.
Yeah. Here's what it is.
It is what.
Yeah. So that's why I wrote that. Um, and uh, yeah, well written,
let us know what you guys think in the comments below.
We wanna hear your thoughts. You guys agree, disagree, whatever. Let us know.
Well.
And also I don't care.
So
I.